Whats up guys! We are back and today we're gonna try and experiment
making a pull tab, pyrotechnic.
Now I found an US army handbook on Amazon
and as I started flipping through it I found a cool tutorial
on how to make a fuse igniter from a book of matches.
The idea being that you can start a fuse by the simple flick of a wrist
That seemed like a pretty dang cool experiment
so i played around with it and made a few modifications to make it even simpler and even more convenient.
Now the materials for this experiment are very simple,
all we're going to need is a book of paper matches. I know back in the day
you could find these at gas stations and hotels
but I just went down to the grocery store where they sell them in large packs
of 50 for just a couple of bucks,
you can't beat that.
Now to kick things off we're gonna make just the igniter itself
from 1 single book of matches it's very easy and this is how it works.
Go ahead and open your book of matches that'll reveal the 4 layers of matches inside.
And if u grab on to the base and just give the cardboard a tug,
it'll separate of that staple and leave your book of matches in 2 different pieces.
If you look at the base of of the matches you'll notice a little staple and that needs to come off,
you can use your fingernails, your teeth a pair of
pliers might be a better way to go or
you can just grab the two cardboard
bases at the bottom that matches and
give it a gentle tug. What we're going to do
next to take the actual cardboard
housing for the match folks we're going
to lay it down on the table so the
striker strip is facing up then we're
going to take both edges and fold them
in toward the center until they meet in
the middle. The two edges of the
cardboard should but up nicely against
each other now to hold them in place
let's just take a piece of electrical
tape and wrap it around where the
striker strip would be on the inside.
Now you can see this forms a little funnel
shape where it's nice and open at the
top closes offer on the striker strip
and then pinches off and gets nice and
tight at the bottom. That's all we need to do with this piece for now so let's
set that to the side and move on to the
matches next. Now working with our
matches is going to be even simpler, all
we have to do is take one of the sets
and lay it flat on the table and then
take both edges and fold them a little
past center so the cardboard folds up
into thirds, the matches will want to
unravel so to hold them in place takes
piece of tape and wrap it around the
bundle about a quarter inch down from
the match head and that right there is
really about it all we have to do now is
take our bundle of matches insert it
down into the striker tube and fold it
all up. Now as you push the bundle of
matches down into the striker tube you
don't want to go too far you want the
heads of the matches to stop above the
stricker strip and you'll know you're there when
your bundle sticks out about a quarter
to half an inch. Now from here what we're
going to do is form a pull tab and to
do that we're just going to take the
top of the striker tube place our finger
right in the center and loop the tip
over until it wraps around and touches
the first piece of tape. Use another
piece of tape to hold the tip in place
and you'll end up with something looking
like this, a little pyrotechnics whistle.
So check it out guys using nothing but a
book of paper matches and a little bit
of tape we create ourselves a really
cool-looking ring pool initiator,
the question is does it work? I based this off
the idea of a ring pull grenade and all
you have to do to activate it is stick
your finger through the loop grab the
base of the bundle firmly with your
other hand and pull it really is just as
simple as that and to get this thing to
ignite a fuse really is pretty simple as
well you can see when you pull the two
apart the friction from the striker
strip on the inside ignites all the
match heads at once, that delivers a lot
of heat and a lot of energy in one
single burst. I love the way these things
light off and with a little bit of
practice you can get them work every
time. Now I should mention that if you
wrap the casings on too tight it's going
to take a lot of force to pull them
apart but even just a little a bit of
friction will set them off but
conversely if you don't wrap them tight
enough there's a good chance that when
you pull them apart they don't let off
at all. Ha, fail. So I personally think it's
better to error on the side of caution
and wrap them a little bit tighter.
Alright, moving on for the fuses the kind
of fuse I like to use is called Visco
fuse, this is a safety firework fuse that
I got from a firework supply company. It
takes about a second in an open flame
for the stuff the light off to get this
stuff to light off with our pull-start
pyro, we only have to make one simple
modification and that's to tie a small
not in the top. Now to get the fuses to
work with our system all we have to do
is take the knotted end and stick it at
the top of our match heads on the bundle
and start rolling it up from the side
Once we've got it all rolled up you're
going to notice that makes a nice little
pyrotechnics bouquet of match heads with
the knotted piece on top and once we
put a little bit of tape around here
we'll be able to tug on that to fuse and
the knot will not slide through. Now go
ahead and make the striker casing like
you did before but this time take the
end of your fuse and push it through
first. Now you can go ahead and wrap the
loop back into position the same way we
did before and our pull string fuse
igniter is complete. So I'm going to put
it to the test for you so we can see how
it works. See, look at that I can't
even get my barbecues igniter to light
anyway but that's okay because we've got pull-start-ignition. Glasses on for
safety. So theoretically we stick our
finger on the loop grab onto the other side and pull.
Whooo! Yeah!
You see my hand just pulling off that sheath thing and
there goes one match lights it looks
like it like the other one and then
within about a seconds or less the fuse
lights off. So it looks like if the error on
the side of making them a little bit
tighter there's a higher chance that
your handle will break off but a lot
higher chance that your fuse will
actually ignite as well. I love this stuff.
The fuse worked guys! That was
amazing that's really good news, that's
very encouraging, let's try that again!
What I'm actually really curious to know
is how slowly can we pull this thing and
still have a go off. I'm gonna pull it
extremely slowly lets see what happens
Feeling quite a bit of tension right now.
Whoa!
That worked!
And the match just fell off but they're still going
but that definitely worked, that definitely worked.
And you see the match heads light off,
and within a fraction of a second the fuse lights off as well. That gets hot really fast guys.
Sweet!
Dang look how bright that fire is!
That really does send off a shower of sparks, doesn't it?
That's what I'm talking about there. And that is
success, I love to see things work!
So, there you have it guys apparently with a
simple book of paper matches and a
little bit of tape, we now have the power
to ignite pyrotechnics with a flick of a
finger. Whoa! Hey, thanks for joining me
for this experiment guys, I'll be looking
for you in the next one. Talk to you then.
Thanks to Amazon for the book, I'll be
sending you guys 25 bucks. Oh wait, I already did!
[Laughs]
Hey guys, thanks for watching and
remember I'm giving away prizes now on
every new video all you have to do to
qualify is: subscribe to my channel, ring
the bell and select to be notified when
my next videos get released. The secret
link to my giveaways will be pinned in
the comments for the first 12 hours. If
you like what I'm doing show your support
right now by giving this video a big
thumbs up and share with a friend.
I love you back and I'll see you next time!